hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
Deus Ex mankind divided is jam-packed
with cultural references Easter eggs
memes and secrets whilst you're making
your way through this dystopian future
here's 20 things you should see with
your own eyes let's start with the video
game references in mankind divided and
the best place to visit is the Future
Passed antiquey shop over in the
palisade region of Prague
it's an antique shop with a bunch of
junk but look past this junk in the
basement in particular and you'll find a
video game treasure trove the first
object you'll notice is the companion
cube from the portal series it's
speculated that within each cube is a
living breathing human being but this
one has been opened so we'll never know
if that fable is true or not next to all
the books is a copy of the legacy of
kain soul reaver
first released on the playstation back
in 1999 on the floor underneath is a
copy of hitman codename 47 first
released on the PC in 2000 and close by
again is another video game icon Lara
Croft and the legend title in the Tomb
Raider series and that one was released
back in 2006 damn that makes me feel old
all these games were published by Eidos
who are also publishers of the Deus Ex
series and speaking of Deus Ex in the
back of the basement is a crate with a
gift at the bottom so throw out all
those cardboard boxes and have a look
inside you should see a copy of human
Revolution the previous game in the Deus
Ex series over in the task force 29
headquarters is a potential nod to the
watchdog's series and the original
protagonist aiden pearce make your way
over to Vincent Black's office and on
the wall is the Hat coat and jumper or
sweater if you prefer worn by Aiden at
the start of watchdogs there's a few
tweaks here to stay away from copyright
infringement but the zipper next sweater
makes me sure that this is a watchdog
reference
Deus Ex mankind divided has a great
Easter Egg for anyone who played human
Revolution to trigger it go back to
Jensen's apartment later in the game and
you'll see two boxes of cereal on the
counter interact with the correct box
and Adam great name by the way we'll
begin to call himself a bold when this
happens
this almost certainly confirms that
Farida Malik from Deus Ex Human
Revolution is alive Malik and I
immediately took off in pursuit
unfortunately the Illuminati were one
step ahead if you can cast your mind
back all those years during human
Revolution Malik is seen executed while
Jenson watches on the main thing to
notice is that Farida caused Jenson spy
boy also take note of the ship the she
pilots Malik just fine Vasily Jetson
keep them safe
go to hell you bastard
Farina well now take a closer look at
the cereal box seen in mankind divided
could Malik still be alive and in hiding
or maybe Adam has a strange stalker
either way pretty cool Easter egg
references to literature can also be
found in Deus Ex during the first
mission you are asked to hack a door if
we instead used the cold 0 4 5 1 the
door will open and a trophy will pop a
heated combination this cold was present
in the original Deus Ex and a whole host
of other video games such as System
Shock 1 & 2 the Fallout series and even
Bioshock all these games are referencing
the novel Fahrenheit 4 5 1 written by
Ray Bradbury back in 1953 which presents
a future world where everyone is plugged
into various sources of entertainment
hmm sounds eerily like 2018 doesn't it
to round this off the books in this
future world are now illegal and are
burned and what temperature does paper
combust at Fahrenheit two four five one
who said video games of literature and
chemistry are unrelated
another dystopian novel is referenced
over in apartment 41 just next to
Jensen's room and this lovely mural on
the wall which reads the void which
binds the book our series of novels this
is from is the Hyperion cantos visiting
this apartment in the early stages of
the game we'll find a man named Yosef
seven laying on a bed with a friend
attempting to encourage him into living
his life there is always hope Yosef do
not despair sadly if we returned later
in the game Yosef has had enough and
Niels motionless in front of his
sculpture unlocking the laptop close by
also references the name Yosef 7 in the
Hyperion cantos series which I have to
admit I haven't read Yosef 7 was a sigh
bridge with many similarities to the
Augmented in Deus Ex let's lighten the
mood a little with some memes it seems
impossible to make a videogame these
days without a meme are 2 creeping in
I'm sure you've experienced the and
Knuckles meme yeah the one where and
Knuckles is added to pretty much
anything and hilarity ensues well Deus
Ex takes this one step further with a
video game called knuckles knuckles
knuckles & knuckles & knuckles this is
also an acknowledgement to the Deus Ex
and official sonic Twitter account that
regularly have banter between one
another and you've guessed it one of
those tweets includes this very game for
sale in mankind divided another popular
meme can be found in the music box over
in the palisade district this may mix is
the music of Buddy Holly and the
god-awful Doge meme which I still can't
get my head around um I must be too old
in here are other subtle nods to albums
from many eras the Beatles Chuck Berry
and Bruce Springsteen need to watch out
for these copycat artists Oh have you
taken a moment to look at the magazines
too there are many popular brands subtly
changed in mankind divided my personal
favorites are the PC geek mag which
looks like a take on PC gamer and the
cabled magazine which must be a
reference to the Wired magazine there
are so many more so have a look around
and tell me what you find for example if
you look around Prague you will see some
political art or graffiti many look to
be inspired by Banksy and his satirical
approach
on political graffiti mankind divided
has a few TV and film references to look
for to the underground task force 29 is
based on the CTU office found in the TV
drama 24 Jack Bauer and Adam Jensen need
to team up at some point
there's loads of references to the movie
Blade Runner and the novel Do Androids
Dream of Electric Sheep mostly it's the
tone the lighting the mood of the entire
game but one reference in particular is
taken from a Blade Runner scene spend
enough time in Jensen's apartment and
the music will play the following
soundbite
could you make it out something about
owls it's from this scene a brilliant
nod to a movie which inspired the Deus
Ex franchise sure would you expect to
see a Tom Hanks comedy referenced in
Deus Ex neither would i but indeed it is
just around the corner from the metro
will be this monstrosity of a building
it looks to be some sort of magic shop
but we've come to see the Volt r3000
machine if it looks familiar it's from
the movie big in which a child asks the
machine to be you've guessed it big
overnight he gets swish
so I thought I'd give Volta a real
knowledge test and ask him if I should
change my underwear this man difficult
but advice taken Thank You Volta bolt I
can say many different things so I
wasted all my money activating him he's
a couple of the others yet another film
reference can be found in the Palisades
region the security firm Saab check
security is a direct nod to the big
lebowski and the building of the same
name it's only a passing reference but I
think it's still worth acknowledging a
quick note about the UFC of the future
the heavy-metal Fighting Championship
takes hard hit into another level nicely
done
let's finish with a freaky trophy an
achievement in Deus Ex mankind divided
during mission 7 you will stumble across
a penguin prints all regal and gold your
task is to carry him all the way to the
end of the level and return him to his
flock it's ten minutes of frustration
and annoyance but once he's home you
will be rewarded in the shape of a
practice kit and one of the most
ridiculous trophies ever created
so there we have it 20 ester eggs and
references I noticed whilst playing Deus
Ex mankind divided I'm sure I have
missed dozens so what have you noticed
please share them in the comments below
I'm at a from Playstation grenade and
that has been our monthly Easter egg
hunt it's been a pleasure I'll see you
next time